good evening everyone it this is Michael
bottles here from order fools calm and
the order flows market analysis for
Thursday March 16 2017 and today was
kind of end of the day at a small loss I
mean it was from decent activity during
the day stock market was steady with the
doll posting a very tiny lost at 20,000
934 rates bounce higher after
yesterday's post FOMC dip with the
two-year yield up about four bases
pointed to kill us to 1.3 for and gold
moved higher up 25 bucks actually to 12
26 so hiring it was up jobless claims
down housing is chugging along so first
a brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures trading
contains stance or risk and it's not for
every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost on jeopardizing one
financial security or lifestyle only
risk Apple should be used for training
annoyed also sufficient risk Apple
should consider trading past performance
not necessarily indicative of future
results tools are used in this
presentation today are the order Phyllis
trader the order of the bottles flip
u-turn and the transition and you know
first market that I'm going to talk
about today was the five years early you
know the first couple hours of trading
it was very very uneventful you know
this is a bit bit like watching paint
dry in the minis ESPYs we're in a very
tight range most of the morning let me
just find my chart here of course I
can't find it now but here we go it was
something very striking something stood
out so much in the order flow that you
know if you didn't notice it if you're
not using order flow you're missing out
you know I don't want to sound like a
shill for flow but you know what the
information you get from order flow is
head and shoulders above anything else
you're going to you know not using it I
don't say anything else but you know if
you're not using a footprint chart
you're really leaving a lot of
the information you know that can be
used for trading and so what happened
here this was this was the five years
this morning and we know we're just sort
of you know coming into seven o'clock
just sort of creating the longest you
notice Oh two and a half to double oh
and a half area here it's a lot of
two-point range or less more or less
then you get to this area right here and
look at this volume 12,000 on the bid
17,000 on the bid negative Delta 11,000
is quite strong you know five years yeah
you to get good numbers you get you know
3,000 4,000 5,000 quite normally but
here you get and you know not an outlier
but you know a big number you know so
here at this price you got 25,000 going
through here you got another 20-some
thousand going through so you know all
you do the math what is that you know
40-some thousand contracts supporting
the market here again five years you do
get good volume you can see here 6,000
6,000 you know but this one is just a
shade stronger and the other thing is
look at this Delta minus 11 93 11,000
393 now your think it you know such a
big Delta why aren't we you know trading
lower I was like that will Hillary
Clinton that video uhhh yr 9 50 points
ahead in the polls you might ask well in
this case why you have such a strong
negative Delta you got everyone in his
brother Sean into this bit here but
there are buyers stepping up and
absorbing all that selling no they're
saying they're standing there you know
palms in you know they take it from the
floor example little palms in or 1 bid
you know people are perhaps zealot is
hella tia and it keeps on it and there's
still one bid one did well and they're
one and a quarter bid next thing you
know they're one and acid and the market
you see how it just pops right up here
boom boom boom even up here you got
another imbalance here selling in
balancing and 4000 watt selling the
balance and the markets going higher you
have two things that's telling you the
market should be going lower yet the
markets rallying you know that piece of
information alone is very valuable when
the market is not acting the way you
think it should be acting that's telling
you something and there's a traitor you
know you should be able to react off
that you know you just get there you
know bad luck
you know I had a cell signal here it
didn't work well take it a step further
and think about why it didn't work it
didn't work because you have a lot of
buyers stepping up here and bidding this
market up and you can see the market you
know again it went up from 22 and a half
god only you know up here sort of goes
sideways for four and a half you know
before we can its way back down a little
bit later but you know what you have
this area here so you're getting along
in here you know even you don't even
need to wait for this bar to finish you
know here once we start coming up here
we got a new bar formed you know you got
some very solid support here so even if
you're getting along in here or if
you're stopped you're just getting your
stop should be just below all this heavy
volume you know if we get back down
through that level and are below it
decidedly you know stay you know you
don't want to be in that you don't want
to be long you know because if all these
buyers are also done buying who's there
to support the market nobody you know
the lower so what happened later did
come back up again you know what's this
level let me draw the strictures draw a
line here okay so call it that level 0 1
again you came down here you got the
same support well you hit a one box up a
little bit you can see the volumes here
at one and a quarter 2000-3000 then now
look we're decidedly below it clearly
below it now we're putting in more
volume down here so you know how the
market it's over again I'm not saying
that this is going to be a level that's
going to be holding for the next couple
weeks or anything like that I'm saying
in the near term yeah the market is
telling you a deer support here okay and
you can see as you came back down again
you bounced it up once twice so before
breaking through it so that was that was
the the most interesting thing in in
that market this morning and I'll take a
look at the SP is real quick ok so the
S&P this is the 10 range chart and you
know it sometimes I'm very interesting
this morning coming into this morning I
was very quiet quieted down obviously
from all the fireworks yesterday
and we had made this high in the morning
water around three o'clock in the
morning this bar closed finished at
three thirty three in the morning then
you went into the next bar okay well you
got your high up there and look at that
you have a big strong negative Delta you
got divergence this is the red line is
is an indicator to prices rejecter but
you're too high strong negative Delta
very strong and then again another
negative Delta next bar off the high and
again you're coming off the high again
negative Delta negative Delta negative
Delta so since three in the morning it's
all been selling you know I mean you can
just 2,000 2,000 1,200 1,200 1,600 you
come into the cash open your trading
down here around 83 you know 84 this
cash opening area and then you just go
sideways for the next half hour you know
back and forth to get a couple positive
deltas finally 2000 and 4000 okay then
you just go in sideways why is it the
market rallying okay I mean you're
starting to get some decent positive
deltas that's a sign of market you know
buyers are in maybe we can start to
rally but then what happens boom you get
the negative Delta again 3000 and then
this one here you finally broke out of
this range that you had been in back
here right you've been trading or
basically between eighty four and a half
and you know 82 we finally broke out of
that area you got down below 82 strong
negative Delta five thousand coming okay
so you're just right off the low and
then you hit the low make a new low here
by a couple of ticks and you shouldn't
going sideways and again this big
selling comes in here minus seven
thousand you know this morning you know
up to this point that kind of clock it
was just you know from the high that you
had made at three thirty three o'clock
rather until ten o'clock it's been
predominantly selling you know so is the
marketing you think the market call is
on a rally off that you know you come in
here you got a big bar here boom another
big rush of spelling coming in you know
seven thousand again you know you get in
these points of controls that are lining
up here side by side you know even back
here and got it sort of a lower well I
don't have the volume profile up but
you know at the time you're getting
another lower point of control for the
day forming in here around 80 and a
quarter it's not looking good it's not
say not looking good it's not looking
like the market is about to start our
turnaround in rally and what happens
when we get another Russia selling new
low new low divergence okay you don't
really rally offer is it small
divergence plus a thousand but again you
know look at all this Delta minus
2000-2002 again you know now here you
know this work gets a bit more
interesting for a little bit of a rally
got to low new low here at 73 75 and you
get positive Delta five thousand strong
that's a good sign it's much better
looking than this one one thousand it's
kind of limp you know the bottom but
this one is quite strong and now okay
maybe maybe maybe we can start to rally
and when you get next bar you got again
a nice strong Delta two strong Delta's
in a row back to back that's very
encouraging sign and this time you have
a ratio you know 407 so you got
divergence got a ratio afterwards you
know there's things I look for then in
the next part of the third bar you
finally get a push up a couple points
wasn't the biggest rally and you just
want to go sideways over the next few
hours so you know it I was excited here
that you know we can get a nice big
rally office but again you know the
rally were to go it just went right up
to unchanged which is pretty much where
we settled for the day so you know even
though I was getting really excited here
that atl do we could be rallying from
this low all the way back up you know I
remember looking at it thinking hey you
know our highs 88 if we could rally from
the low up to the high you're looking at
10 full points and in the end they won
four to go instead it from 78 up to 88
and one from 78 more or less up to 80
you know you got a bearish ratio here
you have to stop and volume up there
2049 it's a very negative number and in
the order flow in the sense that you
know I know there's volume up here to
stop this move or at least put some
resistance up there and you know we
should sort of hit it that was it off my
charts around two-30 this afternoon
okay so something I'd talk about recent
for a while as these 987 tick charts but
i'll show ya this is the bond from
yesterday and today this is the
transition on the 987 tick chart again
I'm not a big fan of trading on
non-policy day especially when you're
expecting something you know the market
did rally all you had to buy here this
one I'm definitely not interested you
know this one okay you can take it but
you know it's couldn't I don't know it's
not a day that I'm looking to trade
yesterday but today right off this low
now you got the transition giving you a
buy and you know it's a nice move from
147 17 18 I looked a 147 20s 20 28 27 28
nice 10-point move in the bonds you know
I've gotta I haven't looked at all these
carts so I'm just sort of going through
them right now with you know guy from
AT&T came over to work on the internet
connection on the phone okay so this is
to the transition in a 987 crude chart
actually I should probably roll on my
crew chart today tomorrow you know going
back to yesterday again you know the
15th was showing it because if I still
got the data up there you know this but
I didn't work out the cell worked out
nicely you know granted the left 930
when the number came out yeah I a
numbers again you know ten o'clock
another cell you know I'll quick by in a
quick sell you know what a lock it went
down that's it you know the hell you
guys overnight a little bit of a
movement there you know and today this
morning 4860 getting along you know all
the way at the 4690 at least you know
this one you know now this one two
o'clock not interested at that time this
one did it didn't make the move you know
there's no reason to be getting short
here when you can't even extend through
this the low of that of that bar
what else do I got Dax know people have
been asking a lot of questions about Dax
lately now I am I license your ex
traitor for what it's worth now a little
I don't think it matters anymore Dax
alert days no let's go back another day
i'm curious as well here let's see this
is the 15th so in order to get some bad
signals here this one didn't work this
one nope make a couple early fails well
you know show you and you got a nice
winter here I'll see a nice winner the
winner went down this one started films
and failed again you don't want a clock
you're not going to be trading Dax if
you have a brain you know we trained
acts during the nestle MC announcement
yeah I don't know if I'd be willing even
still be looking at that so well after
the cash closed already trading Dax come
on if you're doing that I think you like
to live dangerously but anyway this
morning 16th got myself snow here around
the 51 52 area you know trades all the
way down down down down gosh it's all
way down to 10 so it bounces up goes
back down around 10 you know it's nice
move in the decks you know from 50 down
to 10 it's 40 tix get a buy here just
sort of go sideways on you not much and
another by here a little bit this one I
don't think it would been long as
there's no reason to be getting along
the next bar dozen can even take out the
previous bars hi Oh else we got here
nine o'clock yeah a little bit of cell
doesn't really work out probably what
stopped me out just one to also stop me
out this one a little bit of a movement
here this long again you know I like to
let the market take me in you know this
one is what it takes you into neutral
sideways this one takes it in here again
you know any other way to got your stop
you swimming and getting in here at 50
5355 worst-case scenario if
four and a half you should have to stop
down here at least you know 45 so I've
probably stopped you out you know this
one gave you a decent you know decent
entry is this one I don't think was this
one should not have stopped you out
again it's moved from 63 all the way up
into the 80s so that's another 20-point
move the last market i'll look at is my
favorite too probably getting a lot of
people interested in this mini dowel I
feel like a shill for mini out sometimes
but because Ashley use this is you know
what was a 615 is yesterday again you
know get you some of those things I
yesterday Trading Dow go to cash open a
little bit of movement there yeah
something you know i would get out this
one no reason to take because it doesn't
go anywhere it doesn't give you a reason
to be getting along this when you get
shorts they need to get along here you
flip it you get in and out real quick
you know move from 54 up to you know the
64 a couple of ticks this one would have
stopped you out here but again you know
at this time you're probably kicking
back he definitely not going to take
this I don't think right ahead of the
announcement I mean it's 30 minutes
ahead but still no one in the right line
should be trading around that time all
this is one o'clock 10 10 110 115 120
can you get by here came down and got
blown on a day like this you know this
is a tricky day the tricky data trade
this was yesterday okay not today this
was SF post f1 see the same day you have
to give your stops you know first of all
don't think you should be training but
if you are you got to give your stops or
wider berth you can't do a very tight
stop on a day when there's a lot of
volatility expectedly on expectedly
especially on a day that you expect
there to be a lot of Allah till
so you know like I trade like this
normally I that I stop you know just
somewhere right around here I'd probably
need to expand it out a bit you know I
can't just you have it so tight like
that anymore because I know there's a
lot of extra volatility in the market
that you can get you know these pops one
way you'll pop pop pop down and then
make the move that you're looking for
now I'm not saying that just to talk up
this trade I'm just saying it because
you know that's based on my experience I
mean you're trading a market that
normally is a very volatile all son you
know it's going to be very volatile
because of a big event then you gotta
tease you can't you have to adjust your
thinking now that's what a lot of people
go wrong is they don't adjust their
thinking so you get some trades here you
know comes off a bit goes up a bit comes
off a bit again it was just a day again
yeah that's a day I don't normally have
I'm not normally active in the market
I've never been okay so this is today's
Thursday the 16th in the morning yeah
into year we train at two in the morning
if you're in Europe yeah but or Asia are
you betraying this but again you know
stick to the ESPYs at that time actually
because one volume you know this one
this is a lot less volume at that time I
mean you know people are trading it but
still and you don't you know sometimes
you get moved sometimes you don't you
know that's not the problem in because
it's quiet time so if it's not going to
move it to me like watching paint dry so
you're really training as you no doubt
stick to the u.s. hours when the main
index is open so again this one you
shouldn't have taken you know as a
signal there you know the next bar can't
get higher than the previous bar I
always look at that you know I always
let the market take me and so this was
interesting you get a little signal here
get in but then boom it just falls over
here you gotta get out socially you
don't take a take a loss and here's a
trade again it looks like you'd be
getting in but I'd like to be able to
get in within five bars again you don't
create not really an entry they're not
really an entry there
this one you see the entry you know but
then you're getting out there and
getting short it goes back stops you out
get short again just a short stay short
stay short and it's just basically going
right around your entry I'm not your
entry price but I get take our to better
and then finally it'll stop you out
there again you know how many bars it's
gone already one two three four before
five turns around and just go sideways
on you again again i signal here then
later in the day you know this was a
nice move it's gotta be patience right
and you know don't think that hey you
know I got 10,000 an account I could
trade 20 mini dollars no you know I
people do crazy but you know you don't
don't trade poorly margin you know if
you got 10,000 in your account you
should be looking at you know for
contracts three contract four or five
six maybe definitely not not 20 you
gotta save you know part of the thing
with trading right you gotta save your
bullets so to speak you know people i
know people come in hey I gotta account
or two and a half thousand bucks in it
i'm training five lots oh yeah two and a
half thousand bucks in your account
trade one lap and then yeah maybe
something not too volatile but anyway
yeah i'm not gonna keep all go and do
what they're going to do you can sit
there and tell them you don't do it you
sometimes I worked with traders I feel
like I need to do an intervention Chris
Thomas but you know at the end of the
day is it's yeah it's their money but
anyway so this was a nice move here from
the 90 area down to the 60 area this one
you kids you the false start there and
you didn't work out and again yeah at my
I got up to 2 30 today so anyway I don't
think I had the other indicators let me
see if I could find a quick chart on
them real quick gotta add them but
I was going to talk about them people
said well you didn't talk about it
because they lost money that they show
you the deck that doc strange on why
it's back there let me see maybe we
should try to find it chart gosh i was
like--'cause this ok so this is the slip
on the DAX 8 range chart yeah I don't
want to flip on all the charts you
notice the flip is designed for very
short term training i say short term but
then i know people that use it for a bit
longer and it's one of those indicators
where you get a series of losses losses
lawful let me boom you get a massive
winner so it's not for the faint of
heart and you know here you get a buy
signal and then just go sideways on you
this was yesterday this was on the
fifteenth this one again you didn't
really work out you know I think didn't
really work out but you know if
depending on the type trader you are you
know again I know people that like the
scalp for just a few ticks you know
they're just they're happy with
something like this here it pops up and
comes down before you know sorry I want
to talk about that that's one o'clock
now 130 you know this is therefore fomc
again yeah and don't have the Kate
trading decks after the FOMC
announcement no wait till next day so in
you again yelling it's if you're
scalping on market ideally you want to
do it drink a showers I find it more
effective better movements and more
liquidity now people say well will you
forget if your scalp and S&P is during
the cash hours you got thousands up you
know it's going to get done yeah but um
you know I find it moves better
personally so anyway Dax let's see how
this foot did you know he had a little
move down here they move up there
they'll move down there kind of sideways
this one no this one again nice move
from with that 12 10 call here 160 you
down to whatever 145 you buy here to
start
can often fails miserably this yourself
but then came right back with a quick by
and again you buying it around I don't
know 15 20 you know it goes all with the
30s the cell yeah a little bit movement
there here you get a click by turns
around becomes a quick sell you know
again 12 100 where to trade down to figs
down to the 80s you know it's again it's
20 point move can can you take a small
off like this and be patient enough to
catch the big winners when they come you
know here it flips I mean this is what
double flip about is about sometimes you
get this head fake here and then it
shows it strength there so you get your
fake sell us a fake sell but you know
you get your shell that it just flips on
you and you come right back up a little
bit of movement there again here's a
nice one you get in short here somewhere
here 70 you know he goes down here 60
just go sideways but I would've gotten
out then again it's getting short again
here on the 55 area you know down in 45
up till you know 230 so I you know I
should I show you a bunch of charts
hopefully get some ideas of what you
want to do with the market when you're
trading and what to look for it's easier
why I talk about order fold and what you
know things to look for a rather than I
just talked about it indicator on the
chart but you know i created the
indicators because some people don't
want to necessarily honestly not learn
order flow but you know have a hard time
grasping the concepts initially so they
need something that shows them you know
certain patterns certain things in the
market now that's why I created the
indicators so thanks for watching this
and to learn more about trading and
software used in this presentation and
how you can profit from order flow visit
my website WWF of calm thank you